ولكن ما الذي يريده من خلال هذه الزياره
لبكين يبدو ان رئيس الفرنسي اراد قطع
الطريق على روسيا التي تتنامى علاقاتها مع
بكين وذلك منذ الحرب في اوكرانيا مكرون
قال ان الحوار مع الصين ضروري ولا يمكن
ترك المساحه لروسيا ايضا الرئيس الفرنسي
يامل من خلال هذه الزياره في ثني نظيره
اوروبا انحيازا لروسيا او على الاقل يضمن
حياديه من قبل الصين في هذه الازمه بحسب
صحيفه الجارديان وعلى الرغم من ان الصين
تظهر دائما وكانها تسعى الى حل سلمي في
حرب اوكرانيا تقول باريس لم تصل الى حد
انتقاد الرئيس الروسي بوتين بل ستواصل
تزويده بالسلاح زياره ماكرون هي الاولى له
للصين منذ كورونا وسيتخللها اكثر من ست
ساعات ستجمعه بنظيره الصيني لاتاحه المجال
لمناقشه مواضيع عده على اجنده الدولتين
الى جانب حرب اوكرانيا ستشمل الجلسات
قضايا رئيسيه منها تقويه العلاقات
التجاريه مع الصين فوفقا للجارديان يرافق
ماكرون 60 شخصيه من قطاع الاعمال على امل
التوقيع على اتفاقيات جديده ومربحه